[Música]
gente pp
y tú que me miras
[Música]
nada
[Risas]
saben algo el día de hoy me levanté con
un sentimiento algo extraño en mi cabeza
quería hacer un vídeo pero no cualquier
vídeo quería darle un reto a mi mismo
uno que probablemente afecte mi salud
mental y del que muy seguramente terminé
arrepintiéndome y que mejor juego para
esta ocasión que varios o 15 un juego
con una historia de poca madre y no en
mis juegos favoritos así que para este
vídeo especial decidí completar varios
infinite pero quería agregarle un poco
más de sabor así que el día de hoy voy a
averiguar una de las cuestiones más
grandes desde la creación de los humanos
puedes completar varios infinite sin
armas
tendré que entrar en una ciudad en el
cielo salvar a esta chica y adentrarme
en una de las tramas más locas que verás
todo mientras desató el caos y le doy
una paliza a todo el mundo usando solo
mis poderosísimas manos
ahora sé lo que estás pensando este
guapo y carismático hombre debe estar
loco va a ser muy difícil y aunque
tendría razón si hay que intentarlo
antes de comenzar vamos a poner las
reglas de este reto primero obviamente
no puedo usar ningún arma
afortunadamente el juego tiene otros
métodos de apoyo por ejemplo tengo el
listado de quién puede crear portales a
otras dimensiones para darme botiquines
o cobertura tengo los vigorizador es y
por supuesto el clásico cuerpo a cuerpo
claro está aquí nada de esto es tan
efectivo como un arma pero ya me las
arreglaré en conclusión no puedo usar ni
una sola arma solo puede usar la ayuda
de elisabeth los vigorizador es y las
poderosas bombas atómicas que tengo por
brazos segundo el modo fácil está
prohibido porque te estarás preguntando
si el modo fácil todo podría ser mucho
más sencillo sabes por qué no
comparte y tercero no puedo comprar nada
en valioso sin fin de tenemos estas
máquinas en las que puedes comprar
munición salud y sales pero durante todo
el juego no puede comprar absolutamente
nada ni para curarme ni para mis poderes
nada
estas tres reglas son las que tendré que
seguir a lo largo de todo el juego para
completar este desafío será un largo
viaje seguramente mueran muchas veces y
muy seguramente me enojé un montón pero
quién sería yo si no lo intentara
acompáñame en este viaje en donde voy a
completar bioshock infinite sin armas
primero lo primero la dificultad como ya
establecimos al principio el modo fácil
está prohibido así que la opción sensata
sería escoger la dificultad normal pero
no quién crees que soy soy el ser más
rudo de este universo cuando estaba en
el colegio los profesores tenían que
levantar la mano para hablarme a mí
cuando fumo al cigarrillo le da cáncer
así que vamos a completar todo este
desafío en difícil
tráenos a la chica y borrara su deuda
así comienza mi historia conmigo a bordo
de un pequeño bote mientras los locos me
llevan a un faro al parecer mi misión es
rescatar a esta chica y acabar con
cualquiera que se interponga en mi
camino finalmente llegué al misterioso
faro entre explora un poco me llevé todo
el dinero que pude y eventualmente
encontré una persona que claramente está
cómodamente dormida así que mejor no lo
molesto seguir subiendo y llegué a la
cima del faro en donde introduje el
complicadísimo código que me habían dado
con lo que me puse cómodo y un cohete me
lanzó a todo madre hacia el cielo y así
llegué a una ciudad en las nubes
[Música]
sí muy bonita la ciudad pero aquí no
vinimos a hacer turismo aquí vivimos a
reducir la población mundial seguir
avanzando y consiguiendo más dinero pero
fue aquí cuando me encontré con un padre
que quería bautizarme pero casi me ahoga
lo infeliz afortunadamente esto me ayuda
a avanzar y finalmente entró a columbia
es muchísimo esta primera parte me la
pasé explorando la ciudad haciendo un
poco de turismo y conociendo los
ciudadanos que pasa señoras
un peluche de sam bird quiero uno hasta
que llegue a una feria que estaban
celebrando y aprovechando que es domingo
y tengo el día libre me metí un par de
juegos en la feria y puedes apostar que
ganen todos
después de caminar un rato encontré a
esta chica quien me dio mi primer
vigorizador posesión con el que pudo
controlar máquinas y enemigos por un
breve periodo de tiempo así que use mis
habilidades de hacker encontré de nuevo
a los dos locos del bote y seguir
explorando hasta que el alboroto me
llevó a una rifa que esté bigotón está
organizando y adivina que me gane la
rifa es
verdad eso digo yo al parecer en esta
ciudad abunda el racismo y la
desigualdad y el premio en la rifa era
lanzarle una pelota a esta pareja robes
papas me criaron mejor que eso así que
estaba a punto de plantarle la pelota en
toda la cara al bigotón prefiero un
policía me detuvo agresivamente y pronto
se daría cuenta de el grave error que
había cometido
je je je su culpa de que no estaba
tranquila
la gran [ __ ]
efe
cómo
cuál es
después de un buen rato por fin pude
comenzar a pelear y aunque conseguí mi
primera arma ya saben que no la voy a
usar con mis brazos es más que
suficiente así que acabe con muchos
policías y descubrí que las torretas son
más fuertes de lo que pensaba pero por
favor creen que pueden conmigo soy el
protagonista yo no muero
diablos después de pelear con muchos
enemigos y las molestas torretas me di
cuenta de que no era tan fácil como
pensaba así que desarrollé una técnica
maestra que usaría durante todo el juego
golpearlos y correr por mi vida y qué
creés funcionó logre derrotar a mi
primer oleada de enemigos relativamente
fácil
así que comí todo lo que me encontré
para curarme y continué mi camino
encontrando a mi primer gran enemigo el
incendiario
aunque la verdad fue más fácil de lo que
pensaba o sea si trato de achicharrar me
pero lo agarre a puños y terminé
acabando con él rápidamente
gracias a él conseguí mi siguiente
vigorizador beso del [ __ ] con el que
puedo lanzar bolitas de fuego
seguí adelante y nuevamente me encontré
a la pareja del bote pero ahora parece
que están de mi lado pues me dan un jugo
chistoso que me otorga un escudo extra
que se regenera con el tiempo y hey
quién soy yo para quejarme conti 9
aprendí que puedo saltar muy alto y
colgarme unos ganchos que hay en toda la
ciudad y seguir golpeando a toda
criatura viviente con la que me
encontrará eventualmente me encontré con
una pareja amable que no quería pelear
conmigo así que decidí dejarlos
tranquilos
pero dos minutos después la policía
entró de los lance a volar por accidente
aquí tuve una dura pelea con otro
incendiario y una torreta pero haciendo
uso de mi enorme cerebro usé la torreta
para acabar con el incendiario y luego
ya puede destruir tranquilamente la
torreta
continué mi camino y me topé con un
culto bien raro pero rápidamente los
acabé a todos
[Música]
y en el centro de la habitación me
encontré una infusión en bioshock
infinite las infusiones son objetos muy
raros con los que puedes mejorar ya sea
tu salud tu escudo o tu sales que son lo
que necesitas para usarlos vigorizador
es así que esta vez decidí mejorar mi
escudo para que tenga más capacidad y se
regenere más rápido junto a la infusión
encontré unas llaves de un cofre que
había encontrado antes por lo que tuve
que devolverme un montón para abrirlo
pero al menos valió la pena pues adentro
encontré otra infusión con la que mejoré
mis sales
una vez volvía a donde estaba me
encontré con este amable señor jugando
con unos pajaritos así que chocamos las
manos y lo dejé descansar fue aquí en
donde me encontré a otro de los enemigos
que vamos a ver muy seguido en este
juego el cuerpo
un cabrón que golpea durísimo y es
bastante resistente y en esta dificultad
es mucho más molesto pero con un poco de
esfuerzo también acabe con él y de sus
cosas recogí otro vigorizador diablos
estas botellas son geniales
quiero una este nuevo poder me permite
controlar cuervos asesinos y lanzarlos a
mis enemigos y para probarlo acabe con
un par de ellos que apá decidieron más
adelante bueno explore esta zona con un
poco más de calma encontré dentro de una
habitación oculta mi primera pieza de
equipo el equipo son como cartas que me
dan ciertos beneficios pero de momento
esta no voy a poder usarla porque es una
mejora para las armas aunque por suerte
poco tiempo después encontré otra pieza
de equipo que si puede usar esta me da
la habilidad de quemar a los enemigos
que golpeó así que el equipo tan rápido
como pude seguir adelante matando más
enemigos y corriendo por mi vida cuando
era necesario hasta que este robot me
dijo que si quiero continuar debo
deslizarme por estos aero carriles
arriesgando mi vida caerme una muerte
segura así que
nada porque no encontré otra infusión
active un par de palancas y seguí mi
camino pero unos soldados me estaban
esperando más adelante ya estaba listo
para carbonizar les la cara pero
decidieron rendirse y dejarme pasar a
hacer que sean felices
qué
y eso es todo se rinden
[Música]
pero mira es [ __ ] no confiaba mucho en
este ya le iba a quemar la calva pero
mejor lo deje en paz es calvo ya tiene
suficientes problemas dentro de esta
habitación conocía el líder de toda esta
ciudad el padre comentó que no contento
con ser un dictador trató de amenazarme
a jamil escúchame anciano cuando nací yo
le dio una nalgada del doctor y ahora si
tratas de amenazarme
así que hice lo que cualquiera hubiera
hecho destruía ese edificio que me a su
nave y me largué de ahí y gracias al
aero carril finalmente llegué al
monumento island la torre en donde están
cerradas la chica que debo rescatar
aunque más que una torre parecía un
laboratorio se ve que experimentaban con
ella así que mejor me apresuro seguir
subiendo y allí estaba
[Música]
es tan
hermoso pude ver a elizabeth me di
cuenta que tiene poderes de los power
rangers porque la había abriendo un
portal a quién sabe dónde así que fui
aún más arriba pero a mitad de camino me
caí y casi me parto la cara pero al
menos llegue más rápido
y por fin pude encontrarme con elisabeth
esto
a pesar de que unos minutos antes trató
de acribillar me con libros ella y yo
nos hicimos amigos bastante rápido así
que lo siguiente era escapar de la torre
pero schönberg el nave metálica que la
protege y no la deja ir comenzó a
perseguirnos que pasa apoyo quieres
pelear
y eso pensé cuando llegamos a la cima de
la torre todo comenzó a irse a la [ __ ]
pues la torre empezó a colapsar y
elisabed y yo casi nos vamos con dios
pero gracias a mi astucia logré
agarrarme de un aero carril aunque son
verde eso le importa un [ __ ] y siguió
destruyendo todo por lo que terminamos
cayendo al mar
casi me le voy a san pedro pero
elizabeth me salvó la vida y cuando
desperté la encontré echándose unos
camiones con unos desconocidos pero la
convencí de conseguir un dirigible para
escapar a parís en esta parte me quedé
un rato explorando la playa la sala de
juegos y pasando el rato con elisabeth y
de nuevo me encontré con estos 2 creo
que ya debo acostumbrarme bueno al menos
leyeron un bonito collar a elisabeth
unos minutos después la policía nos
estaba bloqueando el camino y no
podíamos avanzar así que elizabeth me
reveló que puede abrir puertas
bloqueadas usando ganzúas porque ella
puede abrir portales interdimensionales
y yo tengo el poder de dios en mis
brazos pero abrimos puertas como la
gente decente que somos salvajes
de repente una extraña chica habló con
elisabeth me pareció sospechoso y trate
de bloquear el paso pero no funcionó
toda la habitación se llenó de silencio
y de otras personas sospechosas pero ya
que hay dos boletos para
que veo una infusión y
qué pasa mis boletos
todo era una trampa y me vio obligado a
masacrar a todos en la habitación
elisabeth se asustó un poco al ver mis
enormes habilidades golpeando gente en
la cara así que salió corriendo pero al
final alcance y nos hicimos amigos de
nuevo y llegamos a un parque y logramos
ver el dirigible que estábamos buscando
[ __ ] qué bonito y esto nos llevará
hasta país
sí
otro peluche
no quiero uno
[ __ ] sin querer comencé una pelea con
la policía yo sólo quería un peluche
[ __ ] sea explorar la zona encontré un
peluche gigante de software y estaba a
punto de tomar un transporte para
continuar pero como la electricidad de
este lugar es una [ __ ] se dañó verán
aquí no usan la electricidad normal en
columbia todo objeto eléctrico es
potenciado por un vigorizador llamado
jinete eléctrico así que tengo que
encontrarlo y para conseguirlo debo ir a
un lugar llamado el salón de los héroes
así que tranquilamente tomamos un
ascensor para llegar pero elizabeth
abrió un portal y el pollo gigante casi
nos mata pero todo bien
de camino si el salón de los héroes
encontré otro vigorizador con el que
puedo lanzar a los enemigos al aire
y fue aquí en donde aparecieron más
enemigos pero esta vez fue mucho más
complicado a los soldados nos derrote
fácilmente pero las torretas eran un
fastidio y tuve que pasar como 10
minutos corriendo del cuervo el infeliz
golpea muy fuerte afortunadamente
después de un rato logré acabar con él y
con los enemigos que quedaban por fin
elisabed y yo llegamos al salón de los
héroes y en la entrada un par de
francotiradores nos estaban esperando
pero con posesión acabe con ellos y
entregas salón resulta que slade un
viejo amigo estaba causando problemas
por aquí así que tuve que jugar sus
juegos para llegar a él acabando con
muchos de sus hombres y enfrentándome a
uno de los enemigos más molestos que
encontraremos en el juego los autómatas
[Música]
en el camino nos enteramos de algo
increíble elisabeth es hija de home
stock
o eso parece pero no le dimos mucha
importancia a un dado que estábamos muy
ocupados esquivando balas de medio mundo
al final alcance ashley y conseguí el
jinete eléctrico
[Música]
ya con el vigorizador en mi poder logre
avanzar y llegar hasta el dirigible que
necesitábamos para largarnos de aquí ya
estábamos a punto de irnos pero
elizabeth se dio cuenta de que no íbamos
a ir precisamente a parís así que se
enojó conmigo y me golpeó con una llave
en toda la frente
mientras estuve inconsciente una facción
rebelde llamados nos vox pópuli se
apoderaron del dirigible elisabeth se
escapó pero a mí sí me atraparon un
genio imbécil sí ya estoy inconsciente
para que golpea de nuevo fue aquí en
donde conocí a daisy fitz roy que es
como la líder de todo este grupo
pero esto para es importante de gemelo
al principio estábamos hablando bien
agustín pero a los pocos segundos me
lanzaron el dirigible de suerte estoy
vivo y no me partir la cara en 800 mil
pedazos al parecer los vox populi están
cansados de la desigualdad y crueldad de
comstor por lo que quieren iniciar una
guerra civil para liberar a columbia así
que ella muy amablemente me obligó a
ayudarlos para que me devolviera mi
dirigible ahora sólo tengo que encontrar
elisabeth y ayuda de una milicia rebelde
a ganar una guerra civil contra un
pastor loco en una ciudad flotante
sencillo en fin dentro de esta fábrica
después de marear a todo el mundo
encontré a elisabeth pero ella no quería
saber nada de mí así que tuve que ir
tras ella y justo cuando la iba alcanzar
conocía que es probablemente el enemigo
más fuerte y más molesto del juego el
handy manny
es como el big daddy de este juego
así que de manera muy educada se
presentó conmigo y me lanzó tres
kilómetros hacia la [ __ ]
afortunadamente gracias a elisabeth pude
salvarme y nos hicimos amigos de nuevo o
algo así ahora nuestra misión es buscar
a un armero para que les proporcione
armas a los bots
encontré venir no lo quieres
de camino entre a una oficina en donde
explotaban a los trabajadores así que
hice lo que cualquier ciudadano honesto
hubiera hecho todo el mundo las cortas
manos arriba como quisiera poder
disparar al aire en este momento
[Música]
aquí los ya están a salvo nana luego de
mi heroica acción elizabeth y yo
continuamos con nuestro camino pero
antes de tomar el ascensor elisabed
encontró el diario de su madre y se
enteró de que en realidad su madre la
odiaba
entramos en el ascensor y recibimos una
llamada
resulta que el dueño de toda esta
fábrica que además de ser un desgraciado
racista que explota a sus trabajadores
quiere conocerme por alguna razón por lo
que tengo que seguir bajando aún más
profundo en su propiedad al bajar del
ascensor un tipo nos estaba esperando
con un par de regalitos el interés del
señor fin se limita estrictamente al
caballero y no le hables hacia él y
sabes
luego de explorar un poco esta zona y
encontrar un par de secretos llegué a
donde se suponía que debía encontrar al
armero pero no estaba la policía lo
había arrestado por ayudar a los
rebeldes así que se lo habían llevado
para
interrogarlo por lo que tuvimos que ir a
buscarlo pero tan pronto salimos fui
atacado por el handy manny créeme no
exagero cuando digo que es el enemigo
más molesto de todo el juego en esta
dificultad puede matarme con dos golpes
y no le hago casi nada de daño
[Música]
tenemos
sí
hola
para acabar con él tuve que paralizarlo
un par de segundos con los vigorizador
es y luego agarrarlo a palos lo malo es
que si me acercaba él me lanzaba un puño
que me dejaba medio muerto hace más de
que me lanzaba electricidad para bajarme
de los ganchos así que tuve que usar de
todo para matarlo todos los vigorizador
es golpearlo cuando estuviera distraído
y golpearlo desde el aire para hacerle
más daño es el enemigo más fuerte con el
que me he enfrentado hasta ahora pero
después de morir varias veces y casi 20
minutos tratando de matarlo finalmente
logré romperle su metálica madre y
acabar con él
[Música]
ya con el camino despejado pudimos
seguir llegando a un teatro en donde el
bigotón me estaba esperando al parecer
el tipo se dio cuenta de que soy una
máquina de matar ultra poderosa y quería
contratarme para hacer su guardaespaldas
pero por favor [ __ ] yo no trabajo para
nadie bueno excepto los que me
contrataron para rescatar a elisabeth
pero eso es algo distinto el tipo lo
tomo mal así que envió a su gente a
matarme pero creo que ya sabemos lo que
pasará
en esta zona fue que me di cuenta de que
las cosas de ir adelante iban a ser
muchísimo más difíciles pues aquí tuve
que enfrentarme primero a un incendiario
que ya de por sí es difícil luego a un
cuerpo que como ya viste antes es
increíblemente molesto y después
destruir a un autómata y como si no
fuera suficiente para avanzar tuve que
destruir a dos torretas terrestres y
otras dos aéreas
algo me dice que más adelante voy a
sufrir mucho más no tienen el
presentimiento de que algo muy malo va a
pasar
después de un rato logramos encontrar al
armero pero estaba un poco magullado y
un poco muerto ya no teníamos quien nos
hiciera las armas que necesitábamos pero
justo en ese momento aparecen de nuevo
estos dos y aquí es cuando comienza todo
este desmadre mental pues para conseguir
las armas tendremos que abrir un
desgarro y viajar a otra dimensión a una
en la que el armero nunca murió lo que
no sabíamos es que viajar a otra
dimensión iba a cambiar muchas más cosas
que solo un armero muerto si prepárate
porque las cosas se ponen más locas
desde aquí ahora solo teníamos que
comprobar que esto haya funcionado y que
el armero estuviera vivo por lo que
tuvimos que devolvernos no sin antes
exterminar a unos cuantos enemigos por
el camino cuando llegamos me di cuenta
de que logramos salvarlo
pero al viajar entre dimensiones entre
una donde murió a una donde está vivo él
ahora está atrapado en una especie de
limbo además de que la policía le quitó
sus herramientas así que claro tenemos
que ir a recuperarlas y como él sabe de
ello vamos a cargar máquinas de decenas
de toneladas hasta aquí ese es un
problema para el dante del futuro las
herramientas están resguardadas en un
depósito de la policía que se encuentra
en lo más profundo de la ciudad por lo
que tenemos que bajar a un lugar llamado
santi town un lugar lleno de sufrimiento
y pobreza sé que ahora no lo parece pero
cuando te tomas en serio la historia de
este juego y te sumerges en su mundo
trata de muchas cosas como el racismo y
la desigualdad de una manera increíble
si no lo has jugado aún no sé qué
esperas para extraer me un poco de todo
este ambiente entre a un bar cercano y
cuando baje al sótano encontré una
guitarra activando así uno de los
momentos más bellos del juego
[Música]
s
veamos
para mí
[Música]
y
piensa perder
como veis
en las calles
eso fue hermoso ahora volvamos a matar
gente
luego de explorar el barrio y hacer
nuevos amigos encontré uno de los retos
más grandes que tendré en este juego
pues al llegar a esta zona no sólo
habrán 300.000 millones de enemigos
queriendo matarme sino que hay dos
torretas gigantes que disparan cohetes
por lo que hacen muchísimo daño y
resisten un montón
ya desde el comienzo todo se veía
complicado pues dado que las torretas
están suspendidas en el aire no había
manera de que me acercará y las agarrara
puñetazos algunas de los mejoradores si
le hacían daño pero iba hacer casi
imposible destruirlas de esta manera no
me a quedar dos horas lanzando los
rayitos mientras corría por mi vida se
me ocurrió una idea para completar esta
zona tengo que usar los desgarros de
elisabeth y afortunadamente aquí cerca
habían dos que me servirían un montón el
primero era una torreta aérea y el
segundo un lanzacohetes automático
así que mi única opción para acabar con
todos estos enemigos era usar los
desgarros de elisabeth mientras los
atacó con mis manos y todos mis
vigorizador es
[Música]
me tomo mucho tiempo pues estos
desgarros serán destruídos cada cinco
segundos y no duraban nada así que tenía
que estar abriendo los desgarros
constantemente lo que hizo de esta zona
algo extremadamente difícil pues no solo
tenía que concentrarme en las torretas
gigantes sino también en todos los
enemigos que venían de todas direcciones
para hacerme carnitas
así que tuve que pelear correr y
esconderme constantemente para que no me
volarán en mil pedazos fue difícil pero
estas torretas probaron no ser dignas de
mi poder así que eventualmente las
destruir
por lo que sólo tuve que acabar con los
enemigos restantes y pude seguir
avanzando
al final encontramos las herramientas
pero como soy muy inteligente no pensé
en cómo demonios y vamos a llevar quién
sabe cuántas toneladas de hierro al
taller dios no planeamos esto
detenidamente jeje en serio para mi
suerte justo en ese momento otro
desgarro apareció ahora tendremos que
viajar a otra dimensión en donde las
herramientas ya estén de vuelta en el
taller la idea de saltar de dimensión en
dimensión no me llamaba mucho la
atención pero tampoco es como si
tuviéramos otra opción pronto
descubrimos que algo andaba mal pues
subiendo de vuelta a las escaleras se
oían disparos y explosiones por todas
partes y al salir una guerra se estaba
librando parece que en esta dimensión en
la que llegamos la guerra entre los boks
y comstock ya había comenzado y se
estaban repartiendo madrazos
revolucionarios por todas partes además
de que en esta dimensión estoy muerto
morí siendo un héroe que ayudó a la
revolución de los boks pero no tengo
tiempo para pensar en nada de esto ahora
después de todos los boxes tienen las
armas que les había prometido así que
ahora tengo que ir a hablar con daisy
para que me devuelva me dirigible de una
vez aunque de camino ayudo un poquito en
la guerra hey no es mi guerra y bien
podría pasar desapercibido pero no puedo
ver todos estos balazos y explosiones
sino involucrarme aunque sea un poco y
para demostrarles a todos la increíble
máquina de matar que soy derribo un
dirigible con mis propias manos
[Música]
[Risas]
un negro
[Música]
dónde
por favor después de un rato los mismos
box que antes creían que era un héroe de
repente tratan de matarme y no entendía
el porqué pero no me va a quedar quieto
mientras me estropean la cara así que de
camino tuve que acabarlos a todos además
de que encontré otro vigorizador y
elisabeth se descompuso
[Música]
daisy se encontraba en esta fábrica pero
desde el momento en el que pisé este
lugar ya se sentía que algo turbio iba a
pasar al parecer daisy está enojada
porque como yo morí en este universo
ella cree que soy un impostor así que
luego de abrirle un agujero en el pecho
al bigotón envía a todo su ejército a
matarme lo que por supuesto incluía a un
montón de soldados un incendiario y un
maldito handyman
[Música]
no sé cuánto tiempo pasó o cuántas veces
morí pero después de un rato y un
esfuerzo sobrehumano logré acabarlos a
todos
[Música]
veis y quería matar a este niño porque
porque sí pero elizabeth no iba a
permitir que esto sucediera por lo que
se descubrió y mató a daisy para poder
salvar a este niño feo esto afecta
profundamente a elizabeth por lo que al
llegar al dirigible se cortó el cabello
y había cambiado por el impacto que le
generó este mundo yo ya quería alargarme
de aquí pero de repente software aparece
y destruye el dirigible por lo que
terminamos estrellando no es quién sabe
dónde
al salir la pareja del bote nos estaba
esperando y por alguna razón me
revelaron que software es invocado por
estas estatuas a través de canciones que
lo traen por lo que me dieron una nota
misteriosa y desaparecieron ahora
nuestra misión es ir a la casa de
comstock a ver si podemos conseguir otra
manera de irnos y una manera de
quitarnos a la cacatúa de encima
aunque claro los enemigos no me lo van a
poner nada fácil
ya con el camino despejado tomé un
transporte para llegar más rápido y en
el camino se me revela una cosa muy
importante estos 2 desquiciados al final
no son tan desquiciado pues ella fue
quien creó la tecnología para que la
ciudad flotar y él es una versión
masculina de ella misma pero de otra
dimensión o sea a sola misma persona
pues la razón por la que ellos aparecen
cuando quieren es porque en algún
momento se vieron afectados por esta
misma tecnología lo que les otorgó la
habilidad de manifestarse en diferentes
realidades así que por eso aparecen
frente a mí y cada vez que necesito algo
de ayuda en fin seguí adelante y enemigo
tras enemigo salía de la nada y cada vez
me daban más problemas de los que
deberían
continúe encontré un par de infusiones y
otro vigorizador y más adelante cuando
estábamos explorando una pequeña
habitación
songbird huele problemas y viene a
investigar pero usando nuestras
habilidades ninja nos escondemos y se va
aunque a elisabeth esto parece afectarle
como ya es costumbre tomamos un ascensor
para llegar más rápido pero un cohetazo
destruye nuestro ascensor por lo que
tuve que bajarme en medio de una batalla
entre box y soldado se llama a crearlos
a todos puedo notar que ya es de hace un
par de horas todo se ha vuelto más
difícil se nota que están los enemigos
comunes son mucho más fuertes así que
derrotar a todos estos soldados
incendiarios va a ser mucho más
complicado además de que como no otro
handyman se une a la pelea complicando
la un millón de veces más lo bueno es
que ya en este punto tengo bastante
experiencia lidiando con todos estos
enemigos y sé cómo atacarlos y en qué
momento huir para que no me hagan
carnitas no me malentiendas aún me costó
mucho derrotarlos y tuve que pasar un
buen rato golpeando esquivando y huyendo
pero al menos pude conseguirlo después
de un rato
después de caminar bastante y
enfrentarme a mil enemigos llegamos a la
casa de comptos pero claro que sí estaba
bloqueada la única manera de entrar era
con una huella de la mano de comstock o
de la madre de elizabeth como esto no
será porque queremos matarlo y eso así
que la única opción restante es lady
como el único problema es que ya sabes
está ligeramente
muerta pero la verdad es nuestra única
opción si queremos avanzar además de que
elizabeth nunca conoció a su madre y
quería verla así que
a qué [ __ ] vamos a saquear tumbas al
llegar al cementerio entramos a la tumba
de lady comstock elizabeth estaba
sorprendida de verla pero también estaba
un poco enojada por ese pequeño asunto
de dejarla encerrada en una torre por
años
de repente la tumba se cierra resulta
que el anciano chistoso ya estaba
esperando que viniéramos así que nos
tendió una trampa por lo que usando unas
máquinas usó los poderes de elisabeth
para manifestar el alma de su madre
muerta se puso turbio y como no como yo
soy el protagonista con los músculos de
acero ahora tengo que pelear contra un
fantasma interdimensional de la madre
muerta de elisabeth y que tengo que ver
yo en todo este drama familiar una
[ __ ] pero a quién le van a llover los
puntazos si no pelean contra el fantasma
[Música]
recuerdas cuando dije que el handy man
era el enemigo más fuerte y molesto del
juego mente y eso era porque hasta ese
momento no había conocido hasta para
esta pelea es de lo más estresante que
he tenido que hacer en el juego hasta
ahora no te miento estuve grabando esta
parte durante una [ __ ] ahora
solamente tratando de derrotarla pero
por qué es tan difícil te estarás
preguntando bueno para empezar tiene más
salud que el handy manny segundo no me
puedo acercar a ella para golpearla
porque en el segundo que me acerco me
soltó un puñetazo que rompe mi escudo y
me quita la mitad de mi salud los
vigorizador es casi ni le hacen daño y
como si esto fuera poco la desgraciada
puede revivir a los muertos y como
estamos en un cementerio ya te imaginas
lo que pasó eso sí que es conveniente
por lo que no solo tuve que pelear
contra ella sino también con un ejército
de 800.000 muertos con metralletas
escopetas y lanzacohetes bueno pero solo
tengo que matar a su ejército y ya
preocuparme tranquilamente de ella
verdad pues no porque no importa cuántas
veces los mates ella los va a seguir
reviviendo una y otra vez
al principio traté de hacerlo la
antigüita lanzándome a lo imbécil y
golpeándolo hasta que me cansara pero
tan pronto me acercaba ella me golpeaba
y los soldados me lanzaban una lluvia de
balas así que no estaba funcionando
tengo a dios de mi lado no hay espera
[Música]
inocencia
cable
[Música]
no
ok
lo intente muchas veces en una ya estaba
a punto de matarla pero me rodearon y me
dieron una paliza
[Música]
al final para derrotarla tuve que
esconderme esperar a que se acercara y
esquivar su ataque y golpearla tanto
como pudiera como te dije estuve más de
una hora con este enemigo pero después
de morir mil veces eventualmente
sucumbió ante mi enorme poder tremenda
paliza negra maldición por fin ahora ya
nunca la veré de nuevo
verdad cuando iba saliendo del
cementerio los hermanos luces me dijeron
que si quería la ayuda de lady comstock
debía encontrar tres desgarros en
distintos lugares para revelar un
misterio así que con las huellas de lady
comptos guiándonos fuimos al primer
desgarros en muchos problemas y luego a
la casa de los hermanos luces por el
segundo pero cuando llegamos al tercer
desgarro adivina quién me estaba
esperando ojos y ella de nuevo así que
nuevamente tuve que luchar contra ella y
más soldados reanimados para poder ver
el último desgarro por lo menos fue un
poco más sencillo que la primera vez
sabía cómo atacarla y no invocado a
tantos soldados como antes así que pude
derrotarla rápidamente
los tres desgarros que teníamos que
encontrar nos revelaron que comstock es
estéril por lo que él no es el verdadero
padre de elizabeth ni su esposa lady
comstock ni los hermanos lutes querían
mantener el secreto por lo que comptos
mandó a asesinar a los dos hermanos y a
su propia esposa para que nadie se
enterara de la verdad para mí ese es que
una vez descubrimos esto las huellas nos
llevaron de nuevo a la casa de comstor
en ese momento me di cuenta de que fui
un idiota al creer que no tendría que
enfrentarme con ella de nuevo pues justo
ahí íbamos a rompernos la cara lo peor
no era que tendría que enfrentarme a
ella de nuevo sino que ahora era en un
área mucho más abierta en la otra al
menos tuve algo de cobertura y lugares
donde esconderme aquí no tengo nada solo
fue en que ninguno de estos idiotas
tenga buena puntería pero si la tienen
ahora al igual que la primera vez que me
enfrenté a ella es más de paciencia que
de cualquier otra cosa no podía matar a
los soldados porque de igual manera ella
los iba a revivir así que para que solo
me enfoqué en ella golpeándola cuando
pudiera usándolos legoriza dores y los
desgarros de elisabeth no me va a dejar
ganar el tercer round te voy a pegar un
baile morboso
quiero
[Música]
luego de derrotarla elisabeth hubo un
momento para hablar con ella y al
escucharse ambas se perdonaron
mutuamente y antes de desaparecer la
madre de elizabeth muy amable ella nos
abrió un camino a la casa de comstor el
final estaba cerca ahora teníamos la
enorme casa de qom stock justo al frente
sabes cuando escuché casa de comptos yo
me imaginaba pues eso una casa y ya no
pensaba que iba a ser esta enorme son
aquellas de todo menos una casa active
esta palanca para subir directamente al
edificio pero solberg apareció de la
nada y me tiró como una muñeca de trapo
a otro edificio
el pollo estuvo a punto de matarme pero
elizabeth se sacrificó para salvarme y
ella le pidió a sauber que la llevará de
vuelta con comstock para que yo siguiera
con vida
[Música]
no va a permitir que esta paloma gigante
se llevara elisabeth así que comencé a
perseguirlos pero ya era tarde intenté
seguirlos pero una espesa neblina no me
dejaba ver un [ __ ] y cuando por fin se
disipó estaba cayendo nieve la verdad no
entendía una [ __ ] pero esa era la
última de mis preocupaciones tenía que
rescatar a elisabeth de nuevo tú no la
pasarás de mí así que entré a la casa de
comstor pero cada vez que avanzaba
encontraba varios desgarros en los que
podía escuchar a elisabeth sufriendo no
tenía tiempo que perder así que enemigo
que encontraba enemigo que mandaba al
gulag de esta zona era muy extraña se
suponía que era el lugar donde convivía
pero parecía más un manicomio además de
que la zona estaba plagada con estos
tipos de enemigos que si me veían harían
que los demás me atacaran la verdad es
que tenía la opción del sigilo para
pasar desapercibido y no tener que
pelear pero
más
en esta zona tuve que explorar varios
lugares distintos para encontrar la
manera de abrir una puerta reforzada y
poder llegar con elisabeth será esto
pero cuando por fin lo hice había
llegado muy tarde
[Música]
comstock había usado los desgarros de
elisabeth para dilatar el tiempo entre
ella y yo por lo que para mí no fueron
más que un par de minutos rompiendo
madres en el manicomio pero para ella
fueron décadas llenas de tortura años en
los que yo nunca llegué a rescatarla y
debido a que perdió la esperanza comptos
la obligó a cumplir su deseo de destruir
todo lo que no fuera como columbia como
esto que había ganado y es por eso que
la elisa desde el futuro usó las fuerzas
que le quedaban para enviarme de vuelta
al pasado y así poder salvar las cabezas
y por su madre que esta vez no voy a
permitir que nadie le hiciera daño a
elisabeth
cuando llegué al laboratorio estaban
vacunando a elisabeth contra él omicron
bueno es eso simplemente la estaban
torturando trate de romper el vidrio
para entrar pero era imposible así que
tenía que subir y apagar los dos
generadores que la mantenían inmóvil
obviamente no iba a ser fácil pues cada
vez que intentaba apagar algunos
soldados torretas y autómatas tratado
antes de tenerme pero ellos claramente
no sabían quién soy así que los destruía
todos y ya con los dos generadores
apagados elisa venzo sus poderes super
sayayin para invocar un tornado y matar
a los dos médicos que la habían
torturado
así que ya con el camino despejado pude
ir a liberar a elisabeth
la verdad es que mi idea era rescatarla
e irnos juntos a tomar unas vacaciones
pero ella quería encontrar a comstock y
acabar con él para que no hiciera sufrir
a nadie más
yo insistí pero ella me amenazó con
tirarme un tornado en la cara y bueno
así que no
ahora nuestro último objetivo era llegar
al dirigible privado de comptos para
hacerlo carnitas a él y a los pocos
soldados que le quedan
como esto sabe que esto es el final por
lo que mientras avanzo me lanza todo lo
que tiene pero qué creés voy por ti
anciano cuantas veces tendremos que
darle una lección anciano
[Música]
cómo
si
eres
al terminar subí a una barcaza que me
llevaría directamente al dirigible pero
ya decía yo que esto iba a ser muy fácil
pues a mitad de camino naves enemigas
comienzan a atacarme lo que más que
difícil es un fastidio primero porque no
son uno o dos enemigos son varios
soldados la mayoría con lanzacohetes y
varias torretas aéreas y segundo como
estoy en un transporte en la mitad del
cielo no tengo donde cubrirme y no puedo
moverme con tanta facilidad
así que usted los vigorizador es para
destruir las torretas y usando los
ganchos invadir los transportes enemigos
para derribarlos
cuando llegamos al dirigible ya sabía
que nos estaba esperando un ejército
pero al ver que no habían notado mi
presencia traté de usar mis
excepcionales habilidades de sigilo pero
nada no es lo mío
resulta que este dirigible es muchísimo
más grande que los demás así que tenía
que derrotar a los enemigos del primer
piso subir derrotar a los del segundo
piso y seguir subiendo aquí ya se estaba
poniendo más difícil la cosa con tantos
soldados y robots que debía destruir
pero después de un rato limpié los
primeros dos pisos de enemigos y subí
hacia el tercer nivel en esta cubierta
lucharía contra el último rezago del
ejército del anciano pues envió todo lo
que le quedaba para detenerme soldados
torretas con cohetes y por supuesto que
no iba a faltar un handy man
esto hubiera sido un problema enorme si
yo no fuera la criatura más fuerte que
existe
gracias aunque
ya no había quien me detuviera así que
recogí todo lo que pude y subí hacia el
último nivel al llegar a la habitación
de comstock encontramos los planos para
la torre de elisabeth y descubrimos que
no estaba diseñada sólo para encerrarla
sino que la torre absorbía su energía y
la hacía más débil y fácil de controlar
la cosa era bastante extraña pero no
había tiempo de pensar en eso ahora como
esto que estaba enfrente de mí al
principio comenzó a hablar con él y
saber y pensé que el cabrón se iba a
disculpar o algo pero solo trató de
llevársela de nuevo pero esta vez yo
estoy aquí un modelo muy simple
antes de morir como estos le dijo a
elizabeth que yo sabía quién era ella en
realidad y de dónde proviene yo no sabía
una [ __ ] o bueno tal vez a lo mejor mi
cerebro se dañó al viajar de dimensión
en dimensión así que para descubrirlo
tenemos que destruir la torre que
debilita a los pobres de elisabeth para
poder ver en algún desgarro toda la
verdad sobre su pasado avanzamos hasta
el mando del dirigible pero los vox
populi llegaron a atacarnos con toda su
flota todas y para colmo software
también iba a venir estaba claro que si
no hacíamos algo pronto nos iríamos
alguna pero en ese momento elizabeth
recordó la tarjeta que le había
entregado y pudo descifrar su
significado por lo que destruyó una de
estas estatuas y sacó el instrumento con
el que controlan a software y siguiendo
las instrucciones de la carta tocó una
melodía que hizo que solberg ahora fuera
nuestro amigo
qué ternura quiere sacarme un ojo no
había tiempo que perder ahora con
software de mi lado sólo hay una cosa
que hacer destruirlo todo eran todos
ellos contra todo lo que soy
mi objetivo esta vez no era únicamente
matar a todo el mundo esta vez debía
proteger el dirigible y evitar que le
hagan daño mientras usa software para
que destruya las naves enemigas está
pelea fue de las más difíciles de todo
el juego porque esta vez no solo tendría
que asegurarme de que no me matarán
también debía encargarme de que no le
hicieran daño al generador que
potenciado al dirigible pues si le
hacían daño perdía esto es una fácil
pero el generador está completamente
expuesto en la mitad de la nave y como
en esta batalla el lugar se llena de
enemigos con lanzacohetes autómatas e
incluso naves que lanzan aún más cohetes
pues como difícil no y más aún si estás
en esta dificultad para terminar con
esto tendría que enviar constantemente a
software para que destruya las naves
enemigas de los bots y como su habilidad
tarda un poco en recargarse tenía que
aguantar un buen tiempo y repeler a la
enorme cantidad de enemigos que
aparecieran mientras tanto
[Música]
para la tierra
hoy que tu mano
[Música]
i
x
[Música]
y
aquí tuve que usar todo lo que aprendí
hasta este momento coloque trampas en el
suelo para poder frenar y distraer a los
enemigos controle a los autómatas para
que me ayudaran a madrear a los demás y
tuve que moverme constantemente por los
aerocas y les para escapar y buscar
oportunidades para atacar yo sabía que
esta era la pelea final así que no me
dejen nada aquí use todo lo que tenía lo
voy a madrear te voy a buscar y te voy a
madrear en un punto me alcancé a
preocupar porque el dirigible se llenó
de demasiados enemigos y no podía
contenerlos a todos así que le estaban
haciendo demasiado daño al generador
pero use mi enorme poder y a base de
rigor iza dores y picassos a todo el
mundo logre retomar el control de la
situación así que enviaron ver un par de
veces más y me enfoqué en destruir
tantos enemigos como pudiera sin morir
por supuesto no sé cuánto tiempo dure en
esta parte pero siento que fue más de
media hora dejan muchos enemigos no me
jodas pero después de una larga y enorme
lucha
con los últimos enemigos y software
destruyó el último dirigible se había
acabado yo había ganado más faltistas
que hay demasiados secreto y uniformidad
que no tengo talento pero estoy
lo que tengo yo no moriré no importa que
mi cuerpo sea destruido por completo mis
deseos de pelear me levantarán porque
son muy grandes y después de eso los
derrotaré pase lo que pase excelente
creo que este es el último dirigible
estoy verde de prisa [ __ ] sea acabó
se acabó lo hice
[Música]
después de más de 15 horas de grabación
morir un millón de veces y tener mis
manos inflamadas de tanto golpear
personas
finalmente complete varios o infinite
sin disparar ni una sola bala así que
para responder a la pregunta del título
puedes completar varios show infinite
sin armas si si puedes bueno el vídeo
técnicamente acaba aquí pero llevo 15
horas en esta historia no me iré sin
mostrarte cómo acaba a pesar de que gane
y le demos trato a columbia que soy la
criatura más poderosa de todo este [ __ ]
mundo desafortunadamente yo sé lo que va
a pasar y aquí comienza la parte más
dura y triste del juego te lo resumiré
un montón pero es algo así después de la
pelea me reuní con elizabeth y le
pedimos a software que destruyera la
torre de inmediato schönberg arrasó con
todo y con la torre destruida elisabed
obtuvo de vuelta su poder completo
pero el instrumento para controlar a
songbird se rompió y el super pollo se
salió de control estaba a punto de venir
a matarnos pero elizabeth osas ultra
instinto para llevarnos al fondo del mar
en donde lastimosamente software muere
[Música]
eres un ser gay
viste lo mejor de ti y por eso te admiro
[Música]
pasaste por varias transformaciones
usted tan poderoso que todos nosotros te
odiamos
[Música]
[ __ ] sea siempre me gustó mucho el
personaje de schönberg y justo cuando
comenzamos a hacernos amigos van y lo
matan
[Música]
elisabeth nos transportó a rapture la
ciudad submarina del primer juego fue
bonito volver a rapture aunque sea por
un segundo pero inevitablemente tuve que
irme elisabed y yo subimos a la
superficie y ella me explicó que era lo
que sucedía el verdadero nombre de
elizabeth es anna anna de wheat es la
hija de nuestro protagonista pero cuando
él se vio inundado en deudas decidió
vender a la niña y cuando sus pecados
eran demasiados como para soportarlos él
decidió bautizarse y adquirir la
identidad de zachary con esto
esto causó que se creara un bucle
infinito en todas las realidades y
comstock nunca desapareciera así que
para acabar con el bucle debían acabar
con comstock antes de que se convirtiera
en comstock lo que significa matarme
antes del bautizo así que elizabeth toma
mi mano y me ahogan en el río
[Música]
y bueno después de casi dos meses de
edición grabar por horas y más de 200 gb
de archivos ahora sabes que para
completar para el show infinito no
necesitas balas cuando tienes pectorales
de titanio
desde hace mucho tenía ganas de hacer un
vídeo algo distinto a lo que acostumbro
hacer y quería hacer algún tipo de reto
como éste y escogí a varios infinite
como el primer juego porque es uno de
mis juegos favoritos tal vez en este
vídeo no le hice justicia a su increíble
historia y a todo lo que el juego tiene
para ofrecer pero créeme si no lo has
jugado qué demonios esperas este vídeo
tomó un gran esfuerzo y bastante tiempo
de mi parte así que espero que te haya
entretenido no tengo en mente seguir con
este tipo de retos en algún futuro del
canal no sé cuándo porque la verdad es
que tomó bastante tiempo hacer un vídeo
de estos pero sí sé que seguiré haciendo
estos retos en algún momento así que no
te despegues del canal además por aquí
debajo dejo mis redes
gracias por ver el vídeo y espero que te
haya quedado claro quién es la persona
más ruda del mundo
adoro este juego
[Música]